Hello Freak bitches.
What's your take on this?
Trump versus the intelligence community jazz that seems to be going on right now
because I couldn't wait to get you in here to get an insider's perspective on
this because I've never seen anything like it.
I mean,
I've never seen anything like what he was,
he was talking shit about flu shots today.
He's like flu shots in the biggest scam ever.
Like,
are you sure you've done research?
Are you a doctor?
Wow.
Well,
yeah,
I know that whole,
and he's,
and he's kind of a point that not appointed,
but he's brought somebody in as an advisor on that who is,
you know,
against vaccinations,
whatever that term is.
And not that the Intel thing.
Uh,
there's so many ways you can take this.
It was,
uh,
you know,
basically it was a self inflicted wound.
It was unnecessary.
There was no reason for him,
uh,
in the early stage of this,
when that narrative started to build about,
oh,
there's this rift building between Trump and the intel community.
It was because of his tweets,
right?
And it was because of him questioning the,
uh,
the intelligence about Russian meddling in our election system.
And now to talk about that just for a second,
of course,
the fucking Russians were meddling.
The Russians had been meddling in US politics and campaigning over here in a
way,
since they've been around as have the Chinese,
as have the Chinese,
you could go back to,
and people should,
this was a fascinating period of time in history back to like 1941 go back to
when the Russians were still in an alliance and a pact with the Nazis.
And so from the Russian perspective,
their goal,
their,
their point was to keep the US out of the war.
And so what did they do?
There's an isolationist wing in the States and Roosevelt was under a lot of
pressure.
Roosevelt was,
was becoming very close to Churchill.
They understood the threat.
He was one of the few people that did at the time.
He understood how important it was going to be for America to get into this
battle.
The UK was about ready to fall.
And so the British were actually running their intelligence operations out of
New York and they had a place over in Rockville Rockefeller Center.
And because they were worried they would have island was going to be run over by
the Nazis.
So you have this going on in the dynamic with the Russians was that they were
still in this pact,
you know,
with the Nazi.
Stalin didn't see this common.
He didn't see that on the Nazis were running a very large propaganda campaign,
a diversion effort to ensure that the Russians wouldn't know that they were
about to invade.
So the Russians spent a great deal of time and money and resource here in the u
s influencing us public opinion about staying out of the war.
There's no reason to be in the world.
Why would you want to get into another war in Europe?
And they bought journalists and,
and uh,
placed,
uh,
newspaper articles.
They paid off journalists.
They were setting up associations that were supposedly independent,
but we're run by the Soviets.
They were influencing unions,
dumping money into unions and bribing basically day to get them to steer their
membership to isolationists,
you know,
uh,
agenda.
So to say that,
oh,
I know if the Russians were meddling,
of course they'd been doing it.
That's the w and then all the way through the Cold War,
you know,
that's,
this is what they do.
So,
you know,
but it it the narrative because it always has to be simplified.
I think as far as the media is concerned,
the narrative was that they influenced the election.
We'll know they were meddling,
but they weren't hacking into election systems.
They weren't hacking into the voting booths and changing these things.
So,
so when you say metal and what they were doing is essentially they were getting
information that was private that was being distributed between the democratic
right convention.
Right.
They were definitely involved in,
in the DNC hacking for instance.
They were definitely involved in thinking how were they involved?
Were they involved?
Were they,
did they directly did the hacking to the Democrats or were they privy to the
information because someone sold it to them or got it to them?
As with most of these things that usually there's cutouts,
right?
So there's,
there's,
there's a pla plausible deniability and so,
um,
but the Russians have been very,
oh,
I'm sorry.
No worries.
The Russians have been very,
um,
adept over the years at,
uh,
creating,
mayhem,
creating chaos around democratic institutions.
Their whole goal is to chip away at public trust in,
in a democracy and not just here in the west,
but everywhere.
I mean,
you know,
and obviously that played out in proxy wars out in Africa.
And so I,
again,
I guess what I'm trying to say is it should have shocked no one that the
Russians would be engaged in this sort of thing.
But,
um,
Trump,
again,
a self inflicted wound,
he hadn't gotten the full briefing shit.
He hadn't seen the intelligence about this.
Uh,
and prior to that,
then he sending out a handful of tweets saying,
I don't know.
I questioned it.
It didn't make any sense.
You have all the opportunity in the world to question the intelligence and the
time to do that.
You know,
you're sitting there,
you're getting the briefings from the heads of the agencies,
which happened.
And then if you notice after that briefing,
his,
his tone changed completely.
And he came out and you know,
okay,
well the Russians were involved,
right?
Um,
and it didn't make it.
Now I had to walk that back.
So then he goes out to the agency and he has a meeting,
which I think was a great thing.
I was really happy to see that he did that.
And so soon in the administration goes out to,
to our headquarters out out there in Virginia.
Um,
and you know,
he got sidetracked,
but that's his personality.
He starts talking about the inauguration numbers.
You start talking about the media,
you know,
the unfair media.
Well,
you know what,
you could just go out there.
Thank [inaudible] people say you're looking forward to working with them to
protect national security interests.
Shake some hands and leave,
but it's not in his nature.
Right?
So he's going to get sidetracked and he's got to talk about other things,
and then that becomes the story.
That's it.
That's I guess what I'm saying,
a balanced perspective.
How did it happen?
Because this is what was confusing to me.
How did the FBI in,
and now originally,
eventually the FBI came around to the CIA's conclusions,
but there for a long time the FBI was disagreeing with CIA
about whether or not the Russians had anything to do with hacking the DNC.
Yeah,
the big,
I think the big disagreement was really over motivation,
right?
I mean,
was that what it was a big part.
It was an evidence based thing that they didn't see any evidence that the
Russians were involved,
which eventually became clear and now there was a rest.
There was an arrest and unprecedented arrest a couple of days ago.
Right?
Yeah.
Well,
I think,
but you're also talking about two different groups.
So the bureau is the FBI as a law enforcement.
So when they look at something,
they're looking at it from a law enforcement perspective.
They're looking at gathering sufficient evidence to prove a case.
Basically,
that's how they look at the agencies,
an Intel operation.
And so they're gab and pieces of information.
You know,
it's not an evidentiary chain thing,
right?
So let's just get,
you know,
the preponderance of Intel.
Let's see where it leads as some of it's going to be conflicting.
Some of it's not well,
well sourced,
but let's all see what it tells us.
You know,
and so part of it is how they approach,
um,
reaching a conclusion.
But you know,
they were both going to get to the same place because he eventually there they
sit down and they compare notes.
Uh,
but part of it was the difference of opinion over the motivation and motivation
is the toughest thing.
One of the toughest things approved in this business.
And intelligence,
you know,
you can say,
okay,
they did this,
but you know,
unless you've got a sore sitting in the tent,
who was there?
And part of the conversation when somebody says,
well,
you know,
this is why are,
this is how we're going to do this.
And this is a reason it without that sort of sourcing or intercepts,
uh,
it's,
it's tough to prove motivation.
So it took a while to kind of get around to that notion and it's still,
to be honest,
you know,
it's still a little bit up near,
we're probably never going to get,
unless again,
we get our hands on a really quality good source.
Uh,
that may still be a little bit up in the air,
but the bottom line is Russian.
She had the Russians were engaged in doing what they always do,
the covert action propaganda campaigns,
whatever it may be.
There's the 30,000 foot view was always the same.
They want it,
they want to,
so a sense of,
of a,
of mistrust.
They want to create some chaos.
They want to,
you know,
kind of chip away at the belief that,
at democracy is a great thing.
And they did.
And look how much time was spent talking about the integrity of the election
system and whether we actually had a legitimate president or not.
That's a win.
So you've got a couple of colonels in the FSB,
which was the old KGB,
uh,
who undoubtedly have been promoted as a result of that operation.
And who got fo someone got arrested from the FSB,
who was that guy?
Yeah,
I didn't get arrested.
I don't have those details in front of me.
I just,
just some token got a pissed off Putin.
Exactly.
Throw him in the fucking wall for awhile.
He just sent the wrong thing,
you know.
Uh,
but that's unprecedented.
Right.
Then they never have luckily arrest there guys like,
um,
well they,
they have for certain things,
for corruption issues.
Um,
if they get sideways,
you know,
from a internal arguments,
then you'll,
you'll,
yeah,
it usually doesn't make the news because nobody really gives a shit outside of
Russia.
And they do now because of this,
because of not because people want to talk about it.
And what bothered me about this,
sorry to interrupt.
You're willing to,
what bothered me about this was the narrative because the narrative was Russia
hacked the,
that's what everybody kept
saying and that's what all these Democrats,
these left wing people were saying to try to pump up this idea that Trump was
not a legitimate president.
Russia hacked the election.
Well know someone,
maybe Russia,
whoever it was,
put that information out that the DNC had sent through private emails,
but the information was what they sent you there.
I mean,
it wasn't,
they didn't hack anything.
Right.
They didn't get into any election machines.
They didn't,
they didn't get into the voting machines.
They didn't do anything other than release information that was supposed to be
private that indicated a bunch of really shady shit.
Yeah,
exactly.
I mean all those,
all those Bernie Sanders,
how pissed off unless you be,
if,
if you're a Bernie Sanders supporter and you're Bernie himself fucked over.
He got,
yeah.
Well he seemed to have made peace.
I guess he's,
he's a politician that even though he says he's not,
I mean
it's just a weirdly principled one.
Yeah,
exactly.
I mean I hit a wide eyed,
Bernie would have been a better candidate.
I think Bernie would have been Joe Biden would have been a better candidate.
I'll let you know.
You always like the person sitting on the bench and then they get in the race
and they're not,
you know that's true too.
Right?
They might have dug up some shit about both of those guys,
but Bernie was an interesting guy and he was not a whole lot of people that are
in his position for as long as he is that have the kind of principles he has.
Like when he was able to say,
you know,
why don't you release the transcripts of all these different speeches you gave
to all these banks that you got paid a quarter million dollars.
And he goes,
I'll happily release mine because I don't have any,
cause I wouldn't take a penny from those people.
I was on a whole lot of people who could say stuff like that in a big debate.
And you know,
they rallied,
they got together and they,
they decided to rig the primaries and they've rigged it.
They really did.
That was what the Russians exposed.
But it,
Debbie Wasserman Schultz,
she was a real piece of work credible.
So I think there's,
and you're right,
and I guess what,
you know what obviously,
what,
what people on that,
uh,
on,
on the,
on the far left side are saying is,
well,
but without that,
if they hadn't released that information,
then it would have been a different ballgame.
And you know that,
right.
Because we wouldn't know how fucking corrupt she was.
Right.
But we wouldn't know the,
Debbie Wasserman Schultz had done what she'd done and Debbie Wasserman Schultz
wouldn't have gotten fired from the DNC and then immediately got hired by
Hillary's campaign.
Yeah.
I mean,
they picked her up in a couple of minutes while she,
obviously they want to keep her happy.
You know how when somebody walking out of that organization with,
with a chip on their shoulder talking.
So especially after what she did for you.
Yeah.
I mean,
they rigged the primaries.
They really did.
And people should be upset about that way more than anything else.
It's id that Russia did something.
When you expose something that you should,
that we should have known,
we should have known about it because it's a crime.
You know,
that kind of corruption is essentially collusion.
It's a crime.
It's a conspiracy.
It's a real conspiracy to they're there,
they're interrupting democratic process and that's what they're doing.
Right,
right.
Well then that was yeah.
Far More so then an outside force doing what you expect them to do anyway.
Frankly,
the Russians did.
They always do.
So I think it would have been a great,
how interesting.
With those big conversations in,
uh,
in,
in the Kremlin,
um,
or at FSB headquarters where they're talking about this.
Yeah.
And they're,
they're thinking about,
and they're planning it.
Someone had to write a note,
right?
Someone had to sit and say,
you know,
I got an idea for an operation.
And they had,
cause they,
you know,
it their bureaucracy like everything else.
And so they would have had to sit and figure this out and then,
uh,
it would have made its way to Putin cause you know,
this obviously the concern over the blow back and the publicity of it all.
So Putin clearly knew what was going on.
Uh,
but again,
that's just the way it works.
Stalin new back in the day and know exactly what they were doing,
trying to influence public opinion here back during the early world war one or
two.
So yeah,
I,
there's no surprise to Chinese do the same thing every,
you know,
every nation that's got the resources.
I mean,
hell,
we,
of course we do it too.
People always say,
well,
but wait,
do it.
Well,
yeah,
of course we do it,
you know,
I'm not saying we don't.
Yeah,
they all do it.
It's half of the weird competition that's going on and you better hope we do it.
And in a sense,
I always say the San people say,
when I talk about,
uh,
you know,
um,
cyber hacking or whatever,
yeah.
People always go,
yeah,
well,
you don't have any right to talk a,
the u s does it as well.
I think it will.
Yeah.
That's actually a good thing,
given how aggressive and how nasty the world is out there and how we're
constantly being hit and attacked,
um,
out in cyberspace.
I mean,
yeah,
we better hope we're good at it.
And,
you know,
if people knew how often,
how consistently and constantly,
uh,
our commercial and a public sector infrastructure is probed and tested and
attacked on a daily basis,
people wouldn't sleep at night,
or they have to do is watch a showtime series homeland to super accurate.
Yeah.